if there's one thing corporate people
are known to be it's eccentric so when
someone publicly humiliates them they
will bite back but where all of us might
humiliate them back and call it a day
jeff bezos decided that he would bite
back at elon musk by ending the
dominance of elon's biggest achievement
tesla and the way he is planning to do
it we think he might just succeed so
strap in because today we're covering
the start of what might be the biggest
automotive feud in history elon's tesla
versus bezos trusted partner rivian now
their feud goes back years centered on
their competing space travel ambitions
bezos blue origin has been fighting nasa
over the agency's decision to contract
with musk's spacex to build a lunar
lander intended to take humans back to
the moon now they'll be competing in the
electric vehicle space too as bezos
throws his weight behind rivien the
hand-picked contender he believes can
take on tesla the company has already
surpassed volkswagen's market
capitalization to become the world's
third largest car company all without
selling a single vehicle this company
the shockingly young startup called
rivien has an interesting history and
more importantly is not trying to be
another tesla but has its own strengths
that tesla simply can't compete with so
let's dive into what each company has to
offer what that means and where it will
take the ev industry as a whole to start
with let's look at some history
background rivian is the brainchild of
mit phd holder robert scarange who
founded the company immediately after
completing college back in 2009 when he
was only 27 years old and while back
then his idea was to make a sports car
competing with tesla's original roadster
eventually he decided that he wasn't
going to go toe-to-toe with tesla and
instead create his own brand and that
little decision right there is going to
matter a lot in the future the company
then called mainstream motors went
through a few versions including one
called avera automotive until finally
settling on rivian automotive and with
that the company set its sights on the
autonomous electric vehicle market two
years later the company was immersed in
both electric vehicle technologies and
autonomous driving capabilities from day
one the automaker set out to create
luxurious and battery-powered vehicles
in 2011 rivien unveiled a sporty coupe
prototype however as we just mentioned
robert decided to scrap that idea before
the entire project was scrapped now
while he didn't want to be another tesla
he had to make sure that his company
would persist and as a result realizing
tesla wasn't really focusing on suvs and
more rugged cars he began to work on
that front and so the automaker made a
shift focusing its manufacturing on
holistic ecosystems of electric vehicles
built for the outdoors the rugged
outdoorsy suvs have remained the
company's focus to this day by the end
of 2017 rivian finally had some products
to show revealing two alpha prototypes
less than a year later those two
prototypes became the r1t pickup and r1s
suv which debuted at the la auto show
with production scheduled to begin in
2020. both vehicles were described as
ready for rough terrain and
semi-autonomous and the company outlined
a plan for its next generation of models
to be fully autonomous a space tesla has
been trying to compete in for years the
two vehicles were impressive in fact
they even got the attention of ford
which invested 500 million dollars
although they would go on to terminate
the contract during the covet 19
pandemic the relationship between the
automakers has reportedly remained
strong and they might collaborate again
in the future around this time the
prototypes also got the attention of
jeff bezos while he was ceo amazon bet
big on the company in 2019 they took a
20 stake in the company and ordered 100
000 delivery van vehicles in 2019 jeff
bezos had a big plan in mind he would
bring his two pet projects blue origin
and rivien onto the global stage at the
same time and that's what happened when
the billionaire hurled himself into
space last summer in his blue origin
rocket arriving at the launch pad in a
rivian truck and blasting off in his
blue origin rocket this move was a
well-calculated and strategic product
placement by bezos and a way for him to
announce to the world what he would be
doing after stepping down as amazon's
ceo the billionaire was finally ready to
compete with elon musk now that he too
had an aerospace and electric vehicle
company and while tesla's explosive
stock growth skyrocketed elon musk to
surpass jeff bezos and be the richest
man in the world rivian might not be far
behind as of right now the company has
slowly started to roll its products off
the production line and well from what
we're seeing they're not only a serious
competitor to tesla's dominance but
might just defeat them entirely because
now we're going to be telling you about
the most shocking part of it all the
market response
now we know that rivien has caught the
eye of big investors like bezos and ford
but the actual scope of just how popular
this company has gotten is mind-blowing
because well if you take a look at the
valuation of tesla when it was at the
stage rivian is at right now they got a
very respectable 2 billion dollars
however when rivien is seen at the same
stage which is today they seem to be
getting a 25 times larger valuation at
around 55 billion dollars stock is no
different after gaining 29 on their
first day of trading the shares have
continued to rise as much as 24 percent
later as a result just two days after
its initial public offering rivian
automotive inc reached a market value of
over 100 billion dollars and while their
losses are disproportionately larger
than early teslas the fact that the
company is as of today the world's fifth
largest automaker by market cap having
delivered only a few electric vehicles
to customers is really saying something
nicholas kolas co-founder of datatrek
research a master of analyzing market
trends himself wrote that rivian's
valuation makes it a legitimate option
for institutional investors who have
previously only had tesla to play the
electric vehicle space and if an 11 year
old company with practically no cars on
the road can suddenly become more
valuable than gm and ford you know that
they mean business that being said as
much as stocks are a good way to judge a
company it's the product not the market
share that actual customers will be
buying so let's now shift our focus to
the cars
tesla as we all know likes to make
futuristic and borderline weird cars for
everyday use from the model 3 sedan
which is the best-selling electric car
in the world to the larger model s sedan
model x suv and model y crossovers the
company has a solid foothold in the
urban car market and while stuff like
their cyber truck and semi may come
eventually as of right now they can't
claim any share in the big and more
utilitarian vehicles and that's where
rivien comes in using their ingenious r1
platform they've come up with exactly
what tesla is missing in the form of a
truck called the r1t and the later
arriving r1s an suv meant to be a
replacement to stuff like range rovers
and that's where we start seeing the
different approaches one of the things
that defined tesla is its novelty i mean
who doesn't like a car with a glass roof
a screen the size of a tablet and no
speedometer right well not really you
see while that stuff may fly with
younger enthusiasts to most common folk
that is a little too jarring compare
that to rivian whose trucks are
futuristic and beautiful without a doubt
but somehow seem more familiar and can
easily fit into your everyday cars and
that combined with their more
utilitarian approach makes the company
extremely desirable to everyone and
that's the gist of it the technical
aspects the production marketing and the
actual management all seem to be solid
as experts all around have said
themselves david kirsch a professor at
the university of maryland's business
school claimed that rivian's team
product and investors all look promising
and that coupled with the fact that
they've managed to gather the spotlight
from tesla even for a bit seems to show
that this little company might turn out
to be tesla's worst nightmare as well as
the american purchaser's dream with
tesla pushing its cyber truck back to
2022 it looks like rivien is going to
beat them to market with their r1t
whether rivian's electric truck can live
up to the hype is anyone's guess and
well on that note we must end today's
video i hope you enjoyed watching it and
if you did be sure to leave a like and
subscribe for more with that take care
and i'll see you guys next time